shifting gears now to the midterm
election there was another round of
primaries last night and trump-backed
candidates had strong showings in some
critical battleground states that could
have big implications for the midterms
and the influence of the former
president is on display ed o'keefe is
tracking all of it from last night ed
good morning good morning tony as you
said another round of decisive wins for
trump-backed republicans last night
including many who've said the 2020
election was stolen let's start in the
swing state of nevada where adam laxalt
will be the gop nominee for u.s senate
he's endorsed by former president trump
and has supported false claims of
election fraud he'll take on democratic
senator catherine cortez masto in the
fall in one of those races that could
determine the balance of power in the
senate also in nevada jim marchant is
the republican nominee for secretary of
state remember in nevada like many other
states the secretary of state is elected
and manages elections martian has said
that he would not have certified the
2020 election results so if he wins in
the fall he's among the trump-backed
deniers of the 2020 election results who
would oversee elections in 2024. then
there's south carolina where republican
congresswoman nancy mace who's been
critical of the former president
defeated trump-backed candidate katie
arrington in the state's first
congressional district but fellow
congressman tom rice one of 10 house
republicans who voted to impeach the
former president lost his reelection bid
to trump back state lawmaker russell
frye and finally a big sign of worry for
democrats from south texas
where republican myra flores decisively
won a special election to replace a
democratic congressman who resigned his
seat early her win is notable because
she's going to represent a latino
district that will become the first ever
mexican-born congresswoman to serve in
the house it's also the first
blue-to-red flip of a house district
that was won by president biden in 2020
and so it's an early warning sign for
democrats of potential things to come
this november nate
ed thank you